The killer always returns
to the scene of the crime.
And so was in Myanmar.
On Thursday,
troops sent to a small village
for what's been described
as a clean up operation.
That's according to Mabel's
ousted shadow government.
They say the military carried out
new airstrikes
and sent troops into the area
to kill anyone who stayed.
CNN has been unable to verify
that report, at least independently.
State security forces, though,
say they were acting as terrorists
when that village was targeted last week
by helicopter gunships and fighter jet
fighter jets.
Anna Coren has the story.
And a warning
her report contains
details and images
many viewers will find disturbing
hobby over your diet or the no go.
My own
grandma on this dusty mound near
a grove of banana trees.
Villagers don't know where to walk.
Everywhere
they turn is another dismembered body,
legs, arms severed heads, human
flesh littering the earth.
To go along with it.
And
now we can't recognize who they are.
This is the man filming this video.
There are so many
hundreds of people had gathered
for a community celebration
last Tuesday in Pasay City,
part of a self-governed district
in Seguin State, northern Myanmar.
The killer.
They come for breakfast
on the eve of ten June,
a Buddhist New Year festival.
Families,
the elderly and dozens
and dozens of children
Well, we are really going to heal, right?
No crisis, man.
What did these kids do wrong?
At 7:45 a.m.
a military jet
dropped a bomb on the building
where they gathered, according
to witnesses.
Minutes later, an army
35 attack helicopter mowed down survivors
and continued to circle
for the next 15 minutes,
firing at anyone
who moved to the mobile room.
All as a child,
we heard a boom
I hit the ground
and there was a huge cloud of smoke.
I got up and realized
my daughter was missing.
I
as the wounded screamed for help.
This man searched among the dead
and injured
for his three year
old daughter and his parents.
Almost the entire world knew
it was a killing field.
There were people scattered everywhere.
A woman with burst
intestines died in front of me.
I was shaking.
Why would they kill their own
civilians then?
And then after several hours,
you found them.
You know I don't cry.
My father was cut in half from the waist.
My mother's body unrecognizable.
My daughter was headless.
He says he lost seven family members.
Others lost their entire family
to the government.
For those who miraculously survived,
the injured were taken
to makeshift medical clinics
and staff treated
their catastrophic wounds
others fled to the safety of the forest.
Coming to terms with the
horror they just witnessed.
I cannot comfort myself, cried
this woman.
Everyone is suffering
with fears of more aerial attacks.
Villagers quickly gathered the bodies
and placed
the countless remains in piles
for cremation.
So we don't want to tell. I don't know.
Burn, burn, burn. The wood is not enough.
Please add the tires, please.
This man,
we are trying
to burn the flesh of the dead.
Sure enough,
a military helicopter did return
just before sunset,
firing more missiles
at those who'd come to cremate the dead.
The day is final
death toll,
according to the national
unity government.
186 people killed.
The deadliest attack
since the junta seized power
in a coup more than two years ago.
The military confirmed the bombings,
saying they were targeting
rebel forces
who've been fighting
Myanmar's military government.
But CNN has interviewed over
half a dozen eyewitnesses
of last week's attack
who say the target was civilians.
This man lost 30 relatives,
including young nieces and nephews.
I don't know why
they targeted a place full
of pregnant women,
children and the elderly.
The military are not human.
They are more savage than animals.
During our interview, a jet flies over 77
jet jet fighter
jet fighters coming out of the
The threat ever present
the day before the guys attack.
The military bombed a school and church
in neighboring Chin State.
According to Myanmar's
national unity government,
nine people were killed,
including the principal,
his wife and their son.
Okay.
And last month in Shan State,
22 people were executed
outside a monastery,
including three monks,
a resistance group said.
CNN obtained this footage
from the opposition
defense forces
and spoke to the coroner
who carried out the post-mortems.
He confirmed the victims were tortured
and had been shot in the head.
While the
latest massacre
sparked international condemnation,
of the junta
and the countries that support them, such
as China and Russia.
The families of the victims say
it's just more empty words
about you alone on the road.
How many more children have to die
before the world's leaders take action?
Pleads this man, grieving
the loss of his baby niece.
He says this is genocide.
Anna Coren, CNN.